en el vídeo anterior vimos la
deshidratación de un alcohol para formar
un al que no en este vídeo veremos la
región selectividad regio selectividad
en qué región de la molécula ocurrirá la
reacción eso es la región selectividad
sabemos que un doble enlace se va a
formar entre nuestros carbonos alfa y
beta pero qué pasa si tenemos diferentes
carbonos beta ahí es donde entra la
región selectividad veamos esta reacción
si yo pongo un h unido al anillo justo
aquí y esta vez pondré un metilo
tratemos de averiguar los productos de
esta reacción de deshidratación si
hacemos reaccionar esta molécula con
ácido sulfúrico y calentamos en donde se
formará el doble enlace identifiquemos
primero nuestras posiciones alfa y beta
sabemos que este es nuestro carbono alfa
sabemos que los carbonos junto a este
son los carbonos beta entonces este es
carbono beta y este también es carbono
beta y sabemos que hay dos hidrógenos en
estos carbonos beta pondré los
hidrógenos
aquí pongo el hidrógeno sabemos que sólo
hay un hidrógeno arriba de este carbono
beta y dos hidrógenos aquí abajo
estos son los carbonos que participan en
el mecanismo llamemos al de arriba teta
1 y el carbono de abajo
beta 2 entonces vamos a dibujar dos
reacciones diferentes si hacemos
reaccionar esto con ácido sulfúrico y
calentamos si creemos que el producto se
formará usando el hidrógeno de la
posición beta sé que el doble enlace se
formará entre el carbono alfa y el beta
voy a dibujar este producto el metil
está aquí yo sé que él o h se va a salir
en el mecanismo y que se formará un
doble enlace entre mi carbono alfa y
beta entonces este es un posible
producto una posible región donde la
reacción ocurre ahora veamos qué pasaría
si la reacción ocurriera por la vía del
kart
92 en este carbono beta 2 dibujemos el
producto para este caso
este es el metil y el lo h se irá al
convertirse en agua mi doble enlace se
forma entre el carbono alfa y el beta de
esta manera aquí tenemos dos productos
diferentes que podemos obtener de esta
reacción la pregunta es cuál de estos
dos se producirá en mayor cantidad como
esta es una reacción región selectiva
vamos a ver los grados de sustitución
para nuestros productos para el primero
que obtuvimos en este ejemplo si nos
fijamos en los carbonos del doble enlace
podemos saber qué tan sustituida está la
molécula bueno aquí hay tres cosas
unidas al doble enlace y aquí hay un
hidrógeno así que este es un al que no
trees sustituido y para el otro producto
aquí está el doble enlace verdad
entonces estos son los dos carbonos de
mi doble enlace y aquí hay un hidrógeno
ya tenemos otro este al que no está
solamente ni sustituido tenemos un al
que no y sustituido y 13 sustituido en
uno de los vídeos anteriores hablamos
sobre que un al que no trees sustituido
es más estable así que este es el
producto más estable y por eso es lógico
pensar que el producto que obtendremos
en mayor cantidad será el al que no tree
sustituido aproximadamente digamos 85
por ciento de nuestro producto final
será el al que no 3 sustituido y sólo
aproximadamente el 15 por ciento será
del al que no ve y sustituido esta es
una reacción región selectiva y el al
que no que se formará más es decir el
producto más estable se le llama
producto de sites efe voy a escribirlo
producto
este será el que se formará más en la
reacción muy bien hagamos otro ejemplo
para predecir el producto que se formará
más usando la región selectividad
empecemos nuevamente con nuestro alcohol
dibujaré un alcohol por aquí y es la
misma reacción la deshidratación de un
alcohol para formar un al que no
entonces una vez más esto lo hacemos
reaccionar con ácido sulfúrico y vamos a
calentar nuevamente vamos a seguir los
pasos del mecanismo primero hay que
determinar cuál es nuestro carbono alfa
este es el que se encuentra unido a lo h
cuántos carbonos beta hay para este
ejemplo bueno este es un carbono beta le
llamaré beta 1 a este le llamaremos beta
y este también es un carbono beta será
beta 3 obtengamos entonces los productos
para las tres posibilidades y luego los
analizaremos con beta 1 sabemos que el
doble enlace se formará entre el carbono
alfa y este carbono beta dibujaré él al
que no que nos quedaría bien el doble
enlace se formará aquí cuando él lo h se
vaya como agua este es un primer posible
producto ahora veamos qué pasaría
usando el b2 con el protón del b2 el
doble enlace se formará entre el carbono
alfa y este beta dibujaré nuestro
esqueleto de carbonos aquí está el
esqueleto y el doble enlace se forma
entre el carbono alfa y el beta 2 esta
vez se forma aquí si hacemos una
comparación entre este producto y el que
obtuvimos con b 1 podemos ver que son la
misma molécula
exactamente la misma molécula una forma
de corroborarlo es ponerles nombre si
les ponemos nombre este sería el carbono
1 y la cadena más larga incluye al doble
enlace entonces este es carbono 2 3 y 4
butano verdad y el doble enlace se
encuentra en la posición 1 así que nos
quedó 1 voten y si queremos el nombre
completo aquí el metil está en la
posición 2 y nos queda 2001 voten o
solamente 2 metil voten y ahora
nombremos a esta molécula muy bien este
es el carbono 1 y este es el 2
este es el 3 y este es el 4 ya se ve
claramente que este también estos metil
1 voten pero es mejor que siempre que no
estén seguros le pongan nombre a las
moléculas así no queda duda aquí
descubrimos que éste
2 son exactamente la misma molécula
entonces hasta ahora sólo tenemos un
posible producto ahora veamos qué pasa
con la posibilidad de tres dibujemos el
producto cuando uno de estos hidrógenos
b3 participa en la reacción nuestro
esqueleto de carbonos queda así
y esta vez el doble enlace se formará
entre el carbono alfa y este carbono
beta 3 justo aquí y este es el otro
posible producto así que sólo tenemos
dos posibles productos para esta
reacción tratemos de descubrir cuál es
el más estable si analizamos este
producto 2 metil 1 voten o ustedes qué
opinan sobre el doble enlace será un
mono sustituido y sustituido 3
sustituido o tetra sustituido si ponemos
los hidrógenos es más fácil ver que sólo
está sustituido entonces este 2 metil 1
bote no es un producto y sustituido y si
observamos este otro producto podemos
ver que hay tres cosas unidas en este
doble enlace y tenemos un hidrógeno por
aquí
este producto es un al que no tres
sustituido sabemos que entre más
sustituido esté un producto más estable
es así que aproximadamente un 90 por
ciento del producto final corresponderá
a este producto el al que no tree
sustituido y sólo el 10% corresponderá
al y sustituido antes de terminar el
vídeo
hablemos rápidamente sobre la estéreo
selectividad ya vimos que la región
selectividad se refiere a la región de
la molécula en la que ocurre la reacción
ahora veamos la estéreo selectividad que
estéreo y somero se formó aquí veamos
una vez más la reacción de
deshidratación con este alcohol
primero identificamos nuestro carbono
alfa este de aquí tenemos dos
posibilidades para los carbonos beta
pero como la molécula es simétrica
cualquiera de los dos está bien
cuáles son los posibles productos que
podemos dibujar para esta reacción vamos
a ver el doble enlace se formará entre
el carbono alfa y el carbono beta
dibujemos el esqueleto de carbonos y
pongamos el doble enlace entre el
carbono alfa y este carbono beta así nos
queda un posible producto que estéreo y
somero es bueno este es el y somero
trans y aquí los hidrógenos están en
posiciones opuestas con respecto al
doble enlace
este es el estéreo y somero trans el
otro posible producto es la versión 6 de
este solo volteamos el trans asís y aquí
los hidrógenos están del mismo lado
obtuvimos dos posibles productos el
trans y el cis de los cuales la forma
trans es más estable así que obtendremos
75% de trans y 25% de cis